في المدينه التي دمرتها قنبله نوويه
امريكيه قبل نحو ثمانيه عقود تجتمع في
هيروشيما اليابانيه الدول السبع الكبار
وعلى راس اولوياتها كبح جماح تطلعات الخصم
الصيني بتوسيع نفوذه العسكري في بحر جنوب
الصين والحاء اول دون ان تكون له اليد
العليا في حركه الاقتصاد العالمي اضافه
الى نقاش العلاقات الصينيه الروسيه
وامكانيه توجيه رسائل تحذيريه لبيجين بعدم
الالتفاف على العقوبات الاقتصاديه
المفروضه على موسكو عبر بيعها منتجات
مزدوجه لاستخدام على ان اللافته في القمه
التي تجمع اكبر الاقتصاديات المتقدمه في
العالم واغنى الدول المتبنيه للديمقراطيه
الليبراليه تاكيد بعض المشاركين فيها انها
لن تسعى الى فك الارتباط الاقتصادي مع
الصين بل الى صياغه معادله متوازنه لا
تصبح معها المخاطر الناجمه عن الاعتما على
دوله او عدد قليل من الدول كبيره بشكل
مفرط بحسب تعبير المستشار الالماني
غير بعيد عنه اليابانيه تنعقد قمه موازيه
في مدينه شيعان الصينيه لا يبدو توقيتها
مجرد مصادفه بحته فبيجين تريد تاكيد بان
لديها خياراتها ايضا من خلال تعزيز حضورها
الاقتصادي في اسيا الوسطى وزياده
استثماراتها هناك في مجال الطاقه فالقمه
التي يشارك فيها رؤساء كازاخستان
وقرغيزستان وطاجيكستان
واوزبكستان تعد الاولى من نوعها منذ تاسيس
العلاقات الرسميه قبل اكثر من ثلاثه عقود
بين بيجين وهذه الدول بعد انهيار الاتحاد
السوفياتي
وستسعى الصين من خلالها الى تعزيز التعاون
الاقتصادي وزياده حجم التبادل التجاري مع
تلك الدول الذي وصل العام الماضي الى نحو
70 ملي ار دولار ولا سيما ان القمه ستشهد
التوقيع على عدد من الاتفاقات التي من
شانها اعطاء دفعه لما يعرف بطريق الحرير
الجديد المشروع الصيني العملاق الذي يبدا
من مدينه شيان ويتضمن انشاء الطرقات وسكك
حديديه ومناطق صناعيه في دول اسيا الوسطى
لتسريع وصول منتجاتها الى الاسواق
العالميه